liberal-covered mandates causing a major
confrontation black lives matter
protesting outside carmine's restaurant
in new york city after three
african-american women from texas got
into a brawl with a hostess over vaccine
passports they claim the asian-american
hostess made racist remarks the tourists
were charged with assault and criminal
mischief surveillance video appears to
show them confronting the hostess after
they were asked to leave okay i'll start
with you dana um
the the claim of racism by the three
women who were ultimately arrested
wasn't made until the next day right
they didn't say it to the manager they
didn't say it to the police when they
responded and it's not on video it's not
on well they say that it's not on the
video well you see like you can see that
in the surveillance video they're from
up above and the and the managers of the
restaurant
obviously very sensitive to this kind of
accusation are adamant that that did not
happen and i'm sure meaning that they
have witnesses there um one of the
things that's terrible for small
businesses is that they already have a
situation where they can't find workers
and you have the jobs the job creators
network has this huge lawsuit against
the administration about the mandate but
they're talking about small businesses
and it's not because they're against man
against vaccines it's the fact that it's
so hard for small businesses to find
workers already you imagine if you're a
young woman and you're thinking and
getting your start in new york city and
you're going to take a job as a hostess
is this worth it because they're the
ones that are on the front line that's
the first person that you see when you
walk into the restaurant it's not a
security guard and one of the things you
have with the government is all these
government agencies have workarounds
so that they don't have to necessarily
get get the vaccine so all of these
perks go to government agencies not to
small businesses and people are really
starting to notice this was we knew that
this was going to happen we pretty we
predicted i predicted it i have the
prediction right here but i can't i'm
not going to go ahead no i'm good all
right greg you have to say what happened
all right just some smart guy on a show
said this like a month ago
yeah two points here can you imagine the
spectacle of a black family going to a
restaurant full of white people they're
told they have to sit outside so you got
quite quite a visual for the winter
right white people in black people out
that's not going to go well which leads
to the next question what's missing the
coven cops is there a force that's going
to be going around enforcing this stuff
now this is i mean this is not the
restaurant's fault if you are a pissed
off protester
protest the people who created the rules
not the poor souls that are forced to
enforce them who have to stand out there
and take the abuse no hostess or
restaurant manager
wants to get in the middle of a racial
conflict especially if it's ginned up
and it involves then protests the videos
from what we could tell uh there were
aggressors the the tourists were the
aggressors but we can't hear anything
but um we knew this was coming yeah we
knew we knew what was coming and and and
hang on harold one second i want to ask
sean we knew that it was coming and it
appears that the asian-american hostess
and we want to be clear about this she
let the three women in the african am
three black women and their vaccines and
then they had their vaccine cards and
then three men joined them they had
their vaccine cards but then there were
another three and then all six of them
came out for the three that didn't have
a vaccine card and that's when the fight
really started and all heck breaks loose
but here's
let's just go for a moment and say let's
say there was a racial slur we don't
know that we don't have audio let's go
that let's go let's go down that charge
i know let's go on that path for a
second what is the right response if
someone makes a racial slur to you do
you gang up on someone three on one and
beat the crap out of that is that no
and so that is the that is not the this
is criminal behavior response yeah right
so and that's not to defend any racial
slurs but um yeah anybody's i don't i
don't like black lives matter i don't
agree with black lives matter but black
lives matter says there's a dis uh
there's a disparate impact on black
families because they're vaccine
hesitant because of american history
they're not getting vaccines and they're
being excluded from restaurants i'm
going to give one truck up to black
lives matter on this one first time ever
so black lives matter decides they're
going to protest and the guardian angels
are out there and they're cursing him
out they're they're
throwing anti-gay slurs at the guardian
angels in it
criminal behavior they assaulted that
asian-american woman they assaulted the
latina who came to her aid they
assaulted the black man and the black
woman that came to her aid they they
were
the video is so clear it is absolutely
intolerable it's not about black people
are hesitant to get vaccines or to show
the card or it might be friction or that
we we follow the rules there's rules
against jaywalking there's rules that
you can't
grab a little person and throttle them
and throw the the uh the co the uh what
are you calling
the border patrol on a horse
it was absolutely the i don't know i
don't exactly get the the uh well you're
talking about you're talking about rules
and laws and processing they assume that
that was right it's very simple they
committed case closed and yeah
if someone has called a name it is not
justification for a subsequent assault
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else